welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is the last day
on our series with our bonus video
number seven
we're gonna learn from the single
richest person on the planet at the time
of this recording with a net worth of
197.7
billion dollars mr bernard arno
[Music]
when i was managing family business
which was in a different sector i
happened to
enter in contact with a group
in france that was
having problems business problems
and in this group there was christian
dior
and i was interested by business
and i wanted to turn around this group
and build on which i think was at the
time
the best asset and the best i said was
christian girl
and and i was interested in christian
dior
for a long time because the first time
you know you are very young but the
first time i was in
new york it's in 71
and i remember the first time i arrived
at
kennedy airport i took a cab
and at the time the president of the u.s
was a richard nixon by the way
they were devaluating the dollar during
the summer
where i was there i bought dollars and
my dollars went down
but i arrived at the airport and
i started to talk to the
cab driver and he loved france
and he was interested in politics so i
asked him
and he did not like nixon so he was
talking
about that he said you love francois
what do you know in front do you know
the french president it was mr pompidou
at the time
nobody here remembers but he said no i
don't know the french president but i
know christianio
and immediately he
stuck me and showed that the name
of christian dior is one of the if not
the most known all over the world
in many countries when i go to china
when i go everywhere
it's the name which is the most well
known so
as far back as 71
[Applause]
i understood the power of a name
it's not enough but i think it's one
reason also
when by chance i was in contact with the
real company i think
it's when i had the idea of doing this
and of course the luxury sector spans
over so many different
products but what do you think the
definition of luxury
is
first of all i don't like very much
the word luxury because you have
something
attached to it which means show off
which mean something of
non-significance something futile
something that is useless
and i think a better definition
is combination of
quality and creativity it's how i define
what we do
obviously these products because of the
very high quality they have
because of the high level of innovation
they are expensive
but the reality
is really behind
the appearance behind the price
it's the quality
and the innovation that people are
looking for
so for me it's a definition and
in the group we are really concentrated
on this
how can we create
the most innovative products
and the creators or the scientists
that work with us in the many
laboratories we have
they have complete freedom to express
new ideas
and after that we have to transform them
in reality all over the
all over the world our culture is based
mainly on creativity
and in a startup the
major reason for success
at the beginning is to have an id a
creative id
an innovative idea that is really
putting the company
with an advance to everybody else
it should be to be successful a game
changer
but it's not enough i think
almost as important as the idea at the
beginning
is the execution and the fact that
[Music]
building on the id must be
really very professional very efficient
and that also makes a difference i have
seen a lot of startups
with very interesting ideas
but with also some other competitors
almost with the same ideas but only one
or two of them are successful it's
because
the execution of their
business plan so it's key
for the long-term success of a
startup to be able to execute
well in the 90s had the idea
of a luxury group
and at the time i was very much
criticized for it
i remember people telling me
does not make sense to put together
so many brands and it was a success
it is a recognized success i have been
lucky i must say
to have fantastic children they are all
of them
interested by the the family business
family business especially in the luxury
area is key
for success
[Music]
when you are in a family you have two
major advantages
one is you can think long term like
louis vuitton for instance
i'm not that much interested by
the number of the next six months what i
am interested
in is that the desire
for the brand will be the same in 10
years as
it is today
[Music]
the second advantage of being a family
business
is to hire people because when people
come to lvmh
they do not come in a group with some
anonymity
they come in a family you are not
just a little person
in a big thing you are a member of the
family and you will be taken care of
as as such you know the success of the
group
is made of the quality of the product
and the quality of the product is a
consequence
of the extraordinary craft men and women
that are working with us we have a
large campaign of hiring young
people that sometimes are not really
thinking of becoming craft men or cuff
women
but once we have given them the id
and once we train them we have a rate of
success
which is near 90 percent and it's very
rewarding for us
to see these young people
being so proud
[Music]
i always try to think of what can we
bring
to a brand if we are looking at buying a
brand
what can the brand be
how can it be improved
also does it fit with the other brands
most of the time it is a competitor but
does it feel a niche
where we could see we are not very much
present and when that happened
i must say we we can
move i am lucky to have met steve jobs
at the beginning of the 2000
and we were talking and joking he told
me
you know bernard i don't know
if in 50 years my iphone will still be a
success
but i can tell you i'm sure everybody
will still drink your dom perigno
you have students in marketing but
i often meet students in marketing
and in spite of the group being number
one
with the students in france in
desirability
to work in the group
i always tell them we don't do marketing
because marketing is against
what a company like us should do
because marketing what is marketing
marketing
is to analyze
what the customer wants and then
try to follow what the customer is
looking for
and test what you
create following these trends
and try to to do it
we do completely differently
we create new products and
sometimes it fails but when it's
successful
the customers follow so the marketing
is not for us part of the product
creation
so marketing is after so marketing
is when we have these products
how with these products which people
want maximize the desire
because our business you ask a question
about luxury
luxury for for me is
how can you create desire so the most
important
word in our business is desire
how to create desire and when you have
the product
then you have to create good
environments
in the shops and you have to present it
well you have to do
well good films if it's a perfume
good advertisement either
in the magazine or in the internet if
it's
if it's a product that the way i see
and we see in my group
the way to the way to put product
in contact with the consumers
when the currency is going down we have
the possibility of increasing gradually
prices
like we did recently in the us five
percent
because our products are so in demand
that we can do it
but obviously we are very fair with the
consumer
when the currency goes back up which can
happen which happened in the past
we do the opposite so we can decrease
prices also
if for instance the dollar comes back up
we can also
play it the other way to be fair with
our
consumers i am interested in business
so in business i think we are in a very
strange
period for several years
money is almost costing
zero if not a negative
interest which means that some companies
has
nvmh for instance when we borrow money
we are paid to borrow money
i think it's dangerous two you have a
lot of money in the markets
three the prices of assets
like stock prices are extremely high
so i am very optimistic for the world
for the long term but i see as
unavoidable
that the crisis happen within the next
few years i cannot tell you exactly when
but bubble are inevitably
building up now and at one point
they will explode it's the first time i
have seen that since i am in business
and since i am in business i have seen
prices
almost every 10 years it very soon will
be
over the last period of 10 years without
anyone i was wondering is techno
technology and the use of
internet universally a good thing in
your business sector
or are there brands that you purposely
try to keep offline
internet is more and more important and
if i judge
by the budget that we spent
in the media we are
reducing gradually the amount spent
in magazine to increase the spending
in the internet all the
internet media so it's more and more
important and what is key also
is the fact that now more and more the
customer
they want to first when they want a
product they go immediately
on their computer on their
telephone and they check the product
so the way a brand
is presented to the world
is extremely influenced
by the internet which explains why
when you are on the site of a brand not
only
you see the product but you see the
history of the brand
you see the craftsmanship which is
behind and more and more customers
are looking at that and they want to
understand
what is really behind the brand
and they like the product but they want
to
see and more the internet it's extremely
easy
and and also they want to be able to buy
the product easily
we have now in many countries including
the uk you can buy your product
and get it very fast in a shop
or if you go on the internet you see
what is available in the shop
in center of london if you want such a
such product
you can find the availability
of the product which is
growing faster and faster and and we
more and more invest in
the way we work with internet company
the problem being there
as you see more and more profitable
because now they
get more and more
smart to manage
their revenues for instance at the
beginning
on facebook when a brand
was sending a message to
its followers you could get them
immediately
today it's not the case when you send a
message
you can get maybe one or two percent
of your followers even a brand like your
that have millions of followers
they don't get the message unless you
pay something
to facebook and then you can go
on many
followers and you can even get
on the competitors followers
if you pay so if you are jira
and if you pay facebook you can send
your products
on the followers of chanel
and for the facebook it's a gold mine
because many brands are doing this and
it's one reason why they are so
profitable not all of them are doing
that yet but more and more are going to
do it
and do you think that the mainstream
platforms such as instagram and facebook
improve the chances of new brands and um
young designers um to establish
themselves
or is it difficult because they're
forced out by bigger companies who can
afford
much uh much more expensive marketing
campaigns such as louis vuitton deal
yeah as i just explained it's more and
more important
because more and more people are looking
at it so
when you do this it's
really extremely efficient it's becoming
extremely costly and obviously for
smaller companies
it's more difficult but it's not
something
that you can absolutely
live with for instance in the group we
have a small company
that is not doing any advertisement
that is not doing so far
what i described on facebook or
internet or
instagram or anything else or snapchat
or something
and this company is small but is growing
50 plus it's doubling every year
because the product is
something that we have created
and that encounter big success
and and we cannot produce enough it's
small
but we started this from scratch
what three years ago four years ago
and this year it will do
50 million and
next year last year it was 25 next year
it will be 100
small profitable so you you
you should not generalize yes
it's very important but you can
succeed at least
at a reasonable size at the beginning
without it
if really the product
is not just marketing if you do if you
do marketing like a real consumer group
i think that is not possible but if you
produce something that is really unique
it's possible people are begging for you
to sell donna karen
dfs levy let's look at givenchy
why aren't you selling any of these
companies and what makes you believe in
these brands that are losing money
for first of all i think selective
distribution
was losing money two years ago but this
year globally
between dfs sephora miami cruise line
it's coming back to profitability mainly
sephora i must say in the u.s
more than dfs but sephora is very very
profitable
and as i said if one day we must sell
something
first we want to turn it around
and make it profitable and for the time
being
it's exactly what we are doing with
every of the brand that you have
mentioned
we are investing for a long time we
are buying investing in startups of any
kind
fashion startup digital startup i think
the best example
i can give you is a sephora you know
when we invested in sephora in the 90s
it was a starter and today it's maybe
the largest
retailer of beauty products in the world
and we have started also very early
beginning of 2000
a digital operation which is based in
san francisco where we have i think
one of the best digital team in the
world
and it's extremely successful for
instance
we're number one seller on the digital
on the web of beauty products in the us
far above amazon you know so we know how
to
manage startups and how to make them
grow
because remember startup the goal of the
startup
is not to stay started the goal of the
startup is to grow
and to become if possible a large
company
with a world that is constantly
globalizing
how do you adapt products and luxury
products to different communities around
the world
for example how dolce and gabbana have
recently released a collection of hijabs
is this something that you think your
own brands will do in the near future
we tend to keep the same products
everywhere we don't
think people are looking
at our products to be
done differently in the country from
another country
i think they want to to buy part
of the european are the view
and we try to keep that we try to
show what we do
in the creativity of our atelier
in france and we we don't think
we should modify
and obviously some products are more
successful
in europe in the u.s
or or in the far east but we try to keep
the same products
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free
in the first line of the description
below and if you're enjoying this
billionaire mindset
series give me a hashtag billionaire
mindset in the comments below
so i can celebrate you one part of the
products should be timeless that's
paradox
to be successful you have to have the
combination between
modernity and timelessness
that that's the combination that we try
to keep
and to have a product from louis vuitton
which is was
started in the middle of the 19th
century
some products are the same
for many years but also they should
represent
the utmost modernity that's the
combination
and well that is what is fun
and a key to success if you want to sign
up for the entire
billionaire mindset series for free and
get the companion bonus pdf calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there